last I talked to you it's been in fear
at frying at first and it was a rather a
different shoot for in fear than normal
ones isn't it tell me a little bit about
that
me Alice and Ian until the actual moment
you shot witnesses that's that's right i
Jeremy approached me with the project he
said I have this idea for shooting
feature was very little script and a lot
of it improvised what do you think I
thought I think you're mental but okay
and we did improv and he hired me and
then I did all my rehearsals on my own
because I'm a character comes in to the
world of these other two characters Lucy
and Tom play by Alison Ian and that was
the first time that we met I literally
opened the door got into the back of a
car and they were like who the hell are
you and that was a fascinating way
because he had no idea of how exactly
you're gonna they were gonna react to
you or how you know the dynamic was
gonna work with thankfully work pretty
well you were filming in Cornwall
weren't you for that and doing a lot of
night shoots it was a three and a half
weeks of solid night shoots in Cornwall
to the point that we had a hotel we
stayed in lowly hotel and I never saw
the view the whole time I was in so I
was a beautiful view were right in the
bay here I'm like I'm sure you are but
to me it's just pitch black so and then
every day and then on the very last day
we saw it and it was a stunning view but
you know because we shall leave early
the whole we need a darkness nearly the
whole movie
so it was Sun of night shoots and then
my time you got home you're in bed
before the Sun came up live like a
bumper they do a Dracula movie now you
know I know exactly okay
yeah it's understated in every movie the
vampires in that they can never
appreciate of you never see that new you
know what looks like in the morning
definitely know if you do one that's got
to be part I'll be like yeah was a
disappointment the view now you filmed
in December as well didn't you although
the actual film itself it's set in
spring time yeah
so what was it like shooting in December
as well very dark and cold yeah I think
it really suited the mood of everyone
involved in the movie as well you know
it's quite a dark movie and the fact you
know that that cold that kind of brings
a certain tension to your body anyway
when you put it into a car a freezing
cold car at the after all the cameras a
pitch dead silent when you're driving
along it was yeah it was it was pretty
it was pretty tough shoot I have to say
there was a scene of a self a knee and
there's a big fight in a forest and that
we shut out the 14th of December
and it was I think minus eight and we
shot from 2 a.m. to 5 a.m. yeah I hated
Jeremy Lovering the director that day
because I wouldn't come to the end of
the day and he said just go just get
kneel down for this part of the scene I
looked over and I went really
ok ok it's like that why don't you just
kneel
I remember you saying that about Jeremy
that it's not a guy you would trust with
your wallet in the context of you know
filming is generally about trust isn't
it we - yeah it doesn't a directive but
there is kind of no trust in this
because it's all sprung on you you said
during the shoot yeah I think you I
think to be honest he should really go
for a mental health check-up because I
think in quite a devious person and I
wouldn't trust him not only in relation
to film in this movie I wouldn't trust
him with my wallet in general that's
wrong Gary's a lovely guy I'm Jon yeah
yeah the way he shot the movie was that
he was constantly playing tricks on all
of us and that does take its toll on in
relation to how you trust a director
when he comes up to you and says this is
gonna happen you're always putting on
the back foot and not knowing exactly
whether to trust him or not and that had
it in every way he take what you taking
away and talk to him about something and
come back and you'd feel why didn't he
talk to me and he played that game
constantly with all of the cast so he's
good at playing games it works very well
in the film I must say it serves it very
well now I was completely freaked out
when I was in fear it's one of those
films that you kind of on the edge you
see gripping it all the way through and
I wondered how worried you are now of
going for a drive in the countryside
well I reckon after the movie comes up
comes out something I'm afraid that I
probably will never get a lift again
things happen when you're in cars yeah I
don't know I don't know when the yeah
it'll be interesting to see whether yeah
with you whether it affects my ability
to to get lifts or if people even give
me a taxi drivers I'm worried about that
but it is hopefully it will generally
terrify people now how did you feel when
you watching it yourself because
obviously you know what happens but did
it still yeah I think Jeremy has built
the tension of Brittany in the movie to
the point that I even jumped out a
couple of points even though I knew they
were coming
this is ridiculous why are you Jen here
for hate this is insane
for today I think he's done a great job
of building that that tension throughout
the movie I'll go talk to you of course
a little bit about Downton and we're
very different worlds and interfere
although you have left forward in time
as you leap out of your seat in fear
within fear how do you have you find the
kind of difference between the world
upstairs and downstairs in that what I
love about it is the fact that I'm the
only character who's managed to do both
and I feel very lucky in that you know
tom has done that that trajectory and
he's gone from basically from servant
into it
your family member and I've loved air
I love the journey unloved beau I love
filming in both because I still get the
kind of Traverse that that the hallowed
stairs you know the downstairs stairs
and I think what's wonderful about
shooting in in both worlds is the fact
that he's constantly really in the
middle and I think that that's what
grave is solidifies Tom genuinely it's
the first probably middle-class person
in the fact that you know he generally
doesn't fit in in either world what
advice would you give him have you could
tell him anything
enjoy the fact that you are someone a
dressier because that's going to change
enjoy your meals get thingies yeah live
it up
tip it up right the car live the lights
at the front of the house break turns
live a little
did you enjoy your doing that have you
got to that on the show I hum returns
yeah I wish you could Ford model-t if
someone can pull my hand I turn in a
Ford Model T of you very impressed those
car is there a there are a hundred years
old
yeah that's quite funny where the
director goes and we just stopped on
that mark okay you do it first and then
I'll do it and then they go you know I'm
just okay you're right anywhere and
there's I mean what would you like to
see happen going forward so obviously
were quite away three series for now be
four series five and so forth hang on
yes weirdest infer Thom I mean what I
think what's been spoken but in the
episodes that's been shown recently is
whether he'll even stay at Downton so
he'll be very interested to see if that
is the case are we likely to see you in
a Christmas or how likely we've seen a
Christmas episode I don't think is
disappear in series 5 or a Christmas
episode yeah Christmas I think I think
we nice of Thomas and around Christmas
and Series fives could be nicer Thomas
turn around Christmas
who knows who knows I don't write this
you know Julian cuz you know the
intervening time let's see let's see
what happens between Christmas and how
the show comes back how much would you
like to see a new love interest on the
horizon of him because obviously sadly
lost his soulmate
I think it'll take a while for Tom to
find anyone and I think it's right for
that for the story and for the character
yeah
Sybil and Tom had that kind of element
of star-crossed lovers and that doesn't
come along very often I think for him
it'll take it'll take quite some time to
get over them to find someone as special
for Tom that's her when you lose a
character I care an actress like Jessica
and of course Dan's done left as well
and Stephens on the show what how does
that feel as one of the actors who's
left behind bereft that they've gone you
miss them as friends you know you
generally do and you missed their their
time on set with you but you know it's
their decisions I mean both of them left
because they don't do other things and
we love them and we wish them well
they're both flying and they're doing
great stuff so I saw I saw Dan I was
actually speaking to him only last week
and I saw him last I was in New York and
I haven't seen Jasper and really no one
has she's disappeared don't know where
she is
last time we spoke also you were having
your first costume fitting for the
imitation game right yeah how's that
been going
it's going great yeah it's really fun I
have to say it's an amazing project and
I feel very lucky to be among once those
cast members fellow cast members and
such talented people I mean Benedict's
incredible Kiera mark Strong Charles
dance
Marty good Matthew beer I can go on and
on but it genuinely amazing people and
it's been a really really great project
tell me a little bit about your role in
that film I play John Kane cross who is
a cryptographer and he was around at the
time of rescue park so he he was there
at the time when sharing broken igner
and he becomes he's one of the team he's
one of the team around around Allen
during that difficult time of trying to
get enigma broken and what Queen look
forward to next for you Alan
hey well in fear coming out obviously
and then you gotta come over epsilon
stamped and then grand pianos coming off
as well which is a thriller that I have
combination with Elijah Wood and John
Cusack in times and Edgerton
and yeah that I don't know when that's
coming out soon but yeah so dude a
couple of sellers of the night lots to
look forward to that and in fear is
fantastic appreciation thank you very
much thank you
you